business france est un établissement
avant tout un réseau présent à travers
le monde avec des collaborateurs
organisation organisé par grandes zones
géographiques et sectoriellement et qui
sont au service des entreprises
françaises dans leur
internationalisation
comment intervenir au niveau de première
contre on intervient à travers un réseau
de correspondants typiquement en
martinique nous sommes représentés par
la cci martinique et plus spécifiquement
le service international cci martinique
aider les entreprises c'est valoriser
tout ce qui est fort déçu c'est au sens
large ireps et plus de
l'internationalisation parce
qu'aujourd'hui on parle export de
produits certes mme sy export de service
et de l'internationalisation que ça
passe aussi surtout dans votre zone par
demain des présences à travers des la
création d'établissements ou de filiales
dans les pays surtout quand on exporte
du service une entreprise martiniquaise
* pour le moins peu mobilisé
oui tout à fait là pas besoin d'être
installés dans différents pays il suffit
qu'elle est qu'elle soit basée
aujourd'hui en martinique elle et des
projets de développement par exemple sur
l'europe on aura des solutions à lui
proposer et en plus
des financements non seulement à travers
les pays france assurances export que je
viens de citer mais également à travers
le ministère des outre-mer et qui nous
avons une convention très importante qui
vient financer totalement ou
partiellement
l'ensemble des actions que nous
proposons aux entreprises ultramarines
vous êtes intervenu dans ce séminaire
non
enterrer son santé de la graine la
population de l'étude ou de l'engouement
des internautes inquiets soyons positifs
de l'engouement voilà vous êtes sur un
marché qui est beaucoup plus large que
la martinique est sur un bassin caribéen
avec une histoire commune
aujourd'hui des ambitions qui semblent
partagés et
voilà je sens qu'ils devraient volonté
une nouvelle génération de martiniquais
qui ont travaillé à l'étranger qui ont
eu des expériences très importante et
qui ont tout de suite cette dynamique
internationale dans leurs projets ça
c'est extrêmement positif